today on campaign check we examine
Labour's claim that rising Bills have
cost families thousands of pounds each
year since 2010 and their plans to
reverse them Labour say conservative LED
governments have cost the average
household almost six thousand pounds in
a decade but do their numbers add up one
of the largest increased cost labour
identify is rail season ticket they say
that by 2020 the average price will have
risen by one thousand seven hundred and
forty pounds for a household with two
regular rail commuters but they don't
take account of inflation that's
important because it identifies the real
impact of changing prices over the years
we put Labour's numbers through the Bank
of England inflation calculator and the
real terms increase in fares is 331
pounds for each ticket that's less than
half the Labour figure labour also said
the cost of childcare has gone up by an
average of almost two thousand pounds a
child since 2010 but these figures also
don't include inflation or the 3.7
billion pounds the government already
spends on free childcare so the real
figure will be significantly lower next
energy Labour say average bills have
risen by 68 pounds but again add
inflation in real terms bills have
fallen by 221 pounds the same goes for
water bills which Labour say have gone
up by 75 pounds but in real terms they'd
fallen by 13 on housing Labor's say the
median annual rent is increased by
almost 2,000 pounds in 10 years but at
inflation and in real terms
rents have fallen by 181 pounds labour
are closer on broadband they see bills
have risen 204 pounds in a decade though
adjusted for inflation it's about a
hundred and fifty two pounds now
Labour's say should they win power
they'll save the same household over
6700 pounds but this is not an average
family 5,000 pounds of Labour's savings
rely on rail fare and childcare savings
that are not available to the majority
of households only 5% of people use a
train more than three times a week which
means it will be highly unusual for a
family to have to season ticket-holder
while Labour's childcare calculation as
we've seen is unreliable and it would
only help those with a child under 4
anyway Labor's say there is a
cost-of-living crisis and while it is
true that wages have been stagnant in
real terms for 10 years this highly
selective analysis is flawed and does
not put a credible figure on the cost to
families